I heard recently that she was talking
about on-screen kissing with you my
first uh like on-screen kiss was with
Millie and then so I just like
kind of just like almost like head
butter yeah Finn wolfhard seen that
interview I'm coming to town
chatting on the Drew Barrymore show The
Stranger Things star responds to his
co-star Millie Bobby Brown
sister who made this confession during a
lie detector test with Vanity Fair you
exclaimed kissing sucks after your first
kiss with Finn wolfhard
is Finn just a lousy kisser he is
she's telling the truth he's a lousy
kisser as fans will recall Billy had
been first locked lips in season one
[Music]
uh water scenes come out of nowhere in
the best possible way it's like romance
fantasy drama and fast forward to 2023
have you told him this
no
he's gonna find out that's okay
we hope so Millie because your longtime
panel did find out you have raised each
other in certain ways how did you feel
about your family member calling you a
lousy kisser yeah you know what I was
fine with it my first uh like on-screen
kiss was with Millie
um and so but I didn't know how to like
approach that in any way and there was
no just was like you're gonna do this
thing and at the end of the take you're
gonna kiss her and then so I just like
kind of just like almost like head
butter and turns out Millie faced plenty
of Hazards on the set of that first
season even from there retro
walkie-talkies
stay here
and then it touched this thing like it
would like scrape across the ceiling
yeah
one time
[Music]
but back to that sloppy smooch looking
back Vince anything but embarrassed I
was 12 so
I'll excuse I'll excuse I probably would
have done the same thing if I was not on
screen in front of the entire world now
as for Drew's approach to on-screen
kissing I even give open mouth you know
yeah
it's your choice to slip me the Tugger I
agree we'll figure that out
I agree there's got to be a little
tongue well maybe a little tongue Church
tongue I love to be funny I want to push
the envelope and as a former Child Star
herself seems Drew just wants her guests
to have a laugh about those early
memories and at the end of the take
you're gonna kiss her and then so I just
like
kind of just like almost like head
butter yeah and then but then yeah yeah
the romantic way of putting it was that
yeah
[Music]